Okay, so I trust that you know how to add an image to this button.
What I will do however,
is walk you through how to add constraints to this image.
I Ctrl + drag from the button in this direction and
selected the option called Top Space, and then Ctrl + dragged from
the button in this direction and selected Leading Space as the option.
Now I've added two constraints here.
If I select any one of them, and then go to the utility area.
I can look under Size Inspector to see that the value of this constraint is
a constant 50 points from the top.
If I select the other constraint I can see that it's value is
a constant 30 points from the leading edge.
After that I went to the assistant editor and
in there I created a new action called Play Slow audio.
Now, this function gets executed any time someone presses this button over here.
So now, I can write code to play audio in this function.